junge generation zeigt grosses
politisches engagement im netz black
light metal freaks ruf user aber
gleichzeitig haben sie wenig vertrauen
in gerade etablierte parteien die die
wahlbeteiligungen von jungen menschen
ist extrem gering viele gehen eben eher
auf die straße als an die wahlurne und
es sieht auch nicht so aus als würde
sich das bei der nächsten wahl ändern
kein wunder meiner meinung nach schauen
wir uns mal die themen an die die jungen
bewegen wir haben gerade schon darüber
gesprochen klimaschutz zum thema
deutschland hätte die klimaziele erfüllt
also das bundesverfassungsgericht selbst
hat geurteilt dass da noch zu wenig an
zukünftige generationen gedacht wurde es
fehlt meiner meinung nach an innovativen
ideen
corona in halb anime sind kinder und
jugendliche meiner meinung nach die
größten verlierer von allen jetzt ganz
aktuell luftfilter in schulen immer noch
nicht da rente ja was olaf scholz da
verspricht also ich bin 25 hab keine
ahnung wer mir meine rente bezahlen wird
und alt ist sind themen ja und dann auch
noch dieser wahlkampf junge menschen
interessieren sich ganz besonders für
inhalte die juckt es nämlich überhaupt
nicht was olaf scholz vor sechs jahren
als sie noch in der grundschule waren
getrieben hat oder ob markus söder und
armin laschet region verstehen oder
nicht das ist denen egal wie wollen
wissen wofür steht dieser kandidat oder
die kandidatin und was bringt er oder
sie mir jetzt und in der zukunft
und all das geht unter
in diesem wahlkampf kam meiner meinung
nach die perspektiven und interessen der
jungen menschen zu kurz ich selbst
moderiert einen tick tor kanal da muss
ich erst mal erklären was bedeutet cdu
und spd weil es nicht klar ist wofür sie
stehen und meiner meinung nach müsste
nicht ich das erklären sondern die
parteien und das finde ich schade das
bewegt mich fürchte wirklich um die
wahlbeteiligung der jungen menschen am
nächsten sonntag und deswegen würde ich
gerne mit euch darüber sprechen
ja es gibt nicht nur eine bringschuld
der parteien sondern auch eine holschuld
dass man vorne weg geschickt finde ich
es wichtig was sie gerade angesprochen
hast es gab auch und das fand ich habe
gar nicht so unwichtig ein aufruf und
herbert grönemeyer in der vergangenen
woche aber genau dieses thema
aufgegriffen hat und letzten endes so
eine art generationenvertrag haben
wollte dass nämlich die älteren bei
ihrem wahlverhalten auch an die jungen
denken hat sicherlich was damit zu tun
dass die wahlberechtigten jugendlichen
sich irgendwo zwischen 15 und 20 prozent
bewegen und diejenigen die etwas älter
sind wenn du bist
ganz gut
ich finde dass das herbert grönemeyer ja
an sich in dieser ansprache an die jungs
mal nicht gut persönlich weiß ich
natürlich auch wie viel in der
musikindustrie wo ich herkomme dass es
einen leicht linken drall hat diese
ganze nummer ja ja die polen sind wir
auf die kurse aber die auf leistung auch
die auch darum ging mir genau das junge
hat das gewese ich will jetzt keine
werbung für
ich habe wahrscheinlich auch so viel
schon für freiheit ist für future hier
das ist verhören soll
aber am ende das überrascht mich weil
wir haben ja so viele formate gesehen
aber vielleicht treffen wir eigentlich
nicht den den kern dessen was
jugendliche wirklich interessiert das
ist ein bisschen angesprochen auch
amelie trifft also ich finde das ganz
toll ist kann man auch mal erwähnen da
muss man auch mal stolz auf sein ist ja
hoffentlich auch er sie erreicht
millionen mit ihrem twitter-account du
hast die wahl sagt alle drei
kanzlerkandidaten interview das ist
schon eine große leistung zu erreichen
gerne aber ich dachte nur ist ja
überrascht nicht deshalb weil er
tausende von formaten gesehen haben in
den traditionellen medien tatsächlich
auch als vor einigen im fernsehen wo
sich die spitzen kandidaten und
kandidatinnen die spitzenkandidatin in
diesem fall haben mit kindern
eingelassen kleinen großen wir haben
auch unser neubau häufig gesehen bei
glanz und bei anderen talkshows wie sich
eingebracht haben wie sie das klimathema
tatsächlich zum großen thema gemacht
haben wir haben eine kanzlerkandidatin
die auf dem klima ticket quasi sich zu
kanzlerkandidaten erklärt hat also das
sind ja sowohl thematisch als auch von
den sender angeboten ja viel mehr kinder
und jugendliche die zumindest auf dem
schirm sind und deswegen überrascht mich
dann natürlich geht es in dem fall nicht
um die kanäle und auch nicht um
journalisten und journalistinnen denn
ich finde gerade wir journalisten
journalisten haben dieser wahl noch mal
besonders viele also auch viele formate
nicht nur unsere freunde vom
zentralredaktion sondern noch viele
weitere tolle formate mir geht es um die
inhalte und mir geht es um das vertrauen
was sie wirklich in die parteien haben
ja da wird sich bemüht ja die haben
jetzt alle instagram accounts und geben
ihr bestes sagen wir mal so aber es geht
mir um die inhalte und um das vertrauen
und das fehlt guckt man sich auch mal
die die wiso videos an das hören die
sich an und natürlich die dann das
vertrauen das recht flöten ja und da
wird wen zu wenig dagegen doppelt
punkten du machst auch noch der traurige
themen die junge leute an gehen du hast
gesagt du bist selbst 25 und du weißt
gar nicht wird eine rente bezahlt das
thema rente ist glaube ich exemplarisch
dafür wie parteien die einerseits auch
sagen sie wollen so viel rücksicht
nehmen auf die bedürfnisse der jungen
generation im klimaschutz beim thema
rente beispielsweise was das thema
nachhaltige finanzen angeht überhaupt
keine rücksicht nehmen auf die finanzen
oder auf die bedürfnisse der jungen
generation richtig aber das hat auch
damit zu tun und das ist bitter dass
sozusagen das jeder zweite wähler bei
der nächsten wahl über 55 ist also
entweder schon rentner oder kurz davor
in die rente einzutreten und die zahl
derjenigen die unter 30 sind die der
anteil beträgt 14 prozent und der unter
40 insgesamt 28 also haben unter
40-jährige weniger deutlich weniger fast
halb so wenig nur wie derjenigen die
über 55 sehen und die rente schon sehen
können oder sie genießen das heißt ganz
klar da werden dinge versprochen die
nicht gehalten werden können die unreal
ist sind sie vielleicht ganz besonders
von der jungen generation gezahlt wird
müssen ich glaube deswegen ganz wichtig
etwas was es in den niederlanden gibt da
gibt es ein institut das jedes
wahlprogramm einem realitäts und
finanzierungs check unterzieht
unabhängiges institut ich habe das
brauchen wir in deutschland noch jedes
wahlprogramm jedes wahlprogramm muss
muss vorher gecheckt werden damit auch
so an sagen die von der linkspartei
früher in rente aber der ente in rente
aber zweitrangig ob
das vielleicht auch so ein bisschen nach
werden ich glaube dass soll uns
vorgeschlagen und ich habe mir natürlich
auch angedachte argument kommt und ja es
ist mir natürlich auch klar dass junge
menschen in der minderheit sein was
wählen angeht es auch geführt ich bin
demokrat ihn genau genau und ich glaube
man darf nicht vergessen es sind
trotzdem jedes einzelne individuum mit
wünschen und ideen und vor allen dingen
eins was noch sehr lange deutschland
begleiten wird und
und gerade dieser wahlkampf ist sehr
sehr knapp es ist jetzt noch sehr sehr
viel bewegung drin da können auch die
jungen noch was vom reisen wenn man sich
um sie bemüht es sie haben eine große
hebelwirkung das sieht man gerade anfang
januar aber auch sagen solange an sie
weil olaf scholz kommt ja schon mit
durchaus klaren botschaften also
mindestlohn 12 euro beispielsweise bei
armin laschet ist hängengeblieben
planfeststellungsbeschluss verfahren
das würde man sagen auch gerade jungen
menschen gegenüber ist so ein bisschen
schwierig oder ja ich hatte da auch
meine
diskussionsrunden in spandau gymnasien
naja ist natürlich einfacher wenn der
kollege kommt und sagt für uns wird es
12 euro mindestlohn geben dass das
natürlich das verfängt sich leichter
warum sagt man die cdu nicht
beispielsweise und wir wollen dass die
gewerkschaften das mit den arbeitgebern
jeweils aushandeln das sagen die doch
also wir haben gesagt dass es eben das
dass es eben eine mindestlohn kommission
gibt und dass eben es nicht ausarten
soll in einen überbietungswettbewerb
sondern dass das dort verhandelt wird ja
mit den verschiedenen akteuren und das
dass der sinnvolle und stabilere weg ist
und das halte ich für seriöse aber
natürlich verfängt sich in zeiten von
erregungszustände so eine zahl einfach
mehr damit wird auch wahlkampf gemacht
ich persönlich halte das nicht für
seriös aber die und meint das wird als
dass die linken zum beispiel sagen okay
nicht 12 euro dann gehen wir auf 13 euro
und dann hat man so ein bisschen
marktplatz so und das finde ich schade
ehrlich gesagt marktplatz wäre auch was
die union eigentlich zumindest bei
helmut kohl
sehr gut konnte marktplatz braucht man
nicht eher sexy gesichter in der
st
aber ich habe jetzt hier rahmen gut
aussehen
so gemacht ja ich würde ich auch gerne
und die die union und ich muss sagen ich
respektiere und schätze philipp antwort
sehr weil sonst wenn er sich
entschuldige mich schon für das was ich
jetzt sage aber es ist meine meinung ich
schätze dich aber sehr philipp abenteuer
und zwar die union hat nichts sexier ist
als film am tor und der wird ja auch
eher älter als jung und mit einem
respekt vorm tor braucht die union nicht
eher um junge leute zu kriegen und
deshalb berbalk ja schon geschafft die
frau bernburg wirkt die partei wirkt
sexy als die union brauche die nicht
frische junge gesichter gegeben eine
liebste winter sitzen geübte winter
total wohl die silberreiher ist total
cool die sehr abdullah ist total cool
also wir haben schon in der in der cdu
wirklich coole leute also im übrigen
auch peter neumann ist auch cdu-mitglied
was die meisten gar nicht so richtig auf
dem schirm haben wir haben in der cdu
gute leute aber man sieht das natürlich
immer nur eine retrospektive
und da muss man natürlich auch sagen
dass man vielleicht auch eine erneuerung
schub mit dem letzten kabinettsbildung
dass meine persönliche meinung nach
hätte machen können so haben sie einige
minister werden nein warum nicht na ja
weil ich erst mal mich für den bundestag
ich habe ein spannender und swing state
ich arbeite seit dem jahr dran dass ich
in spandau nach vorne komme dass sich
die menschen emotional abhole und dass
die themen sich verfangen dass ich den
auftrag bekommen bundestag meinte er
sieht man dieses ganze elend von dem
zukunftsteam von armin laschet respekt
vor ihrer arbeit und respekt wie sie
sich da einbringen aber und respekt von
einer partei die versucht sich neu
aufzuladen das hört man ja auch das
totale ist da nach 16 jahren angela
merkel ja alles tatsächlich auch
zentriert hat aber hier muss man sagen
sie sind mitglied des zukunftsteams sie
wollen nicht minister werden sie wollen
jetzt in den in den in den bundestag
über spandau kommen was die wählerinnen
und wähler nicht welche schätzung nicht
wissen sie was die wählerinnen und
wähler nicht schätzen wenn jemand der
noch nicht mal den bundestag ist er
solle doch konnte sich hinsetzt und sagt
ich wäre gerne ministers nicht wünsch
dir was ja aber es geht doch darum dass
auch die menschen erst mal jemanden
legitimieren ins parlament zu kommen
dass man die mehrheiten das in der
demokratie den mehrheiten für sich ein
wo ihn und die sind dass sie ihm hat
damit soll zugelassen könntest du
antwortest du gut sein auf dieses
zukunftsthema was mit inhalten zu tun
ich stehe für kultur und
kreativwirtschaft ich komme aus der
praxis ich kenne die nöte und sorgen der
künstlerinnen künstler und ich habe für
mich selber in auftrag und gemeinsam mit
dem was die menschen in spannender
betrifft wohnen bauen verkehr usw und
wenn ich die legitimation wird kommen
ins parlament zu ziehen und dort in den
ausschüssen zu arbeiten dann habe ich
schon eine menge erreicht und sollte
gott meiner sünder seele gnädig sein und
mir auch noch irgendwann am zug kommen
lassen dann werde ich das auch gerne
dankbar annehmen ich will nicht kneifen
aber es kann doch nicht mein anspruch
sein mich hinzusetzen sagen er hat mich
in zukunft den berufen ja unter
ministerium gegangen
wir haben wir haben eine kultur
staatsministerin monika grütters und die
macht ihren job gut in der pandemie hat
sie wirklich über zwei milliarden klar
gemacht aus ihrem ressort die den
künstlern zugeflossen sind das kann man
jetzt nicht aus einer laune heraus ihren
abendlichen user stunden so ein anspruch
erheben sondern da ich sehe was da
gemacht wurde ich war ja mit in den
gremien das geld verteilt haben an
künstlern und weiß was es bedeutet diese
gelder erst mal ran zu karren das ist
man die spd geht er immer von respekt
aus ich finde es respektvoll jetzt
einfach mal zu sagen muss da mal ganz
entspannt
[Musik]